l'incendie du Vieux Montréal a fait 7
morts à la mi-mars la plupart des
victimes étaient des visiteurs et
quelques jours plus tard Montréal
s'engageait à mettre les bouchées
doubles pour multiplier les inspections
dont on a une responsabilité partagée
pour l'inspection mais les données
transmises par le Service incendie de
Montréal à Radio-Canada ne reflète pas
ce qu'annonçait la mairesse en fait il y
a eu en moyenne 92 inspections par mois
dans l'arrondissement Ville-Marie entre
janvier et mars et lorsque le Blitz est
censé avoir commencé la moyenne tombe à
environ 34 inspections par mois on ne
décélération point d'accélération cet
ancien chef aux opérations du Sim
s'explique mal comment le rythme a pu
s'inverser après l'incendie du 16 mars
c'était questionnable mais c'est pas
justifiable d'aucune façon
ça vraiment pas de sens
l'opposition réclame des comptes à
l'administration et jugent que la
situation est problématique au service
incendie si les chiffres dans un blitz
sont moindres que avant un bled il y a
certainement un problème ça ne rassure
ça ne rassure pas mais moi
personnellement ça ne rassure pas les
moraller et il y a la sécurité des gens
qui en dépendent le signe explique cette
baisse par une sélection plus fine des
bâtiments à inspecter c'est vraiment
en lien avec l'impact des bâtiments qui
sont visés la complexité d'effectuer
l'inspection je considère quand même ça
un bled parce que l'effort qui est fait
là d'analyse de où on doit travailler et
fait et bien fait elle met aussi en
avant le résultat des inspections
réalisées depuis début avril sur environ
500 inspections dans tout Montréal on a
décelé près de 2000 non conformité 12
mise en demeure pour des mesures à
prendre en urgence ont été envoyés au
propriétaire
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal